zweiten lok dann können wir uns nicht
leisten der meinung ist wahrscheinlich
jeder man möchte auch einfach keinen
zweiten lok tor mir nun zugeschaltet
professor klaus dieter zastrow hygiene
experte professor wir hören uns jetzt
immer wieder wir merken es auch es wird
kälter der herbst und der winter stehen
vor der tür
was bedeutet das jetzt vor allem in
zeiten der korona pandemie na gut klar
es wird kälter es wird der winter kommen
aber ich sehe das nicht so dramatisch
wie es immer so beschrieben wird
wir verlagern natürlich das leben mehr
nach innen aber auch damit gibt es dann
weniger ich sag mal in
anführungsstrichen massenveranstaltungen
wie zum beispiel an den stränden oder
irgendwelche feste man muss jetzt auch
ein klein bisschen also ich finde es
übrigens alles gut was jetzt beschlossen
worden ist das finde ich sehr wichtig
und ich habe ja schon mal betont dass
man natürlich diese maßnahmen auch
tatsächlich umsetzen muss man muss dann
natürlich auch kontrollieren und dann
gegebenenfalls falls es immer noch um
vernünftige leute gibt bußgelder und
zwar auch empfindliche bußgelder
verhängen
den soll man sonst macht das ja alles
gar keinen sinn ich sehe das aber um
darauf zurückzukommen nicht so
dramatisch denn wenn sie die zahlen von
heute sehen dann sind wir wieder bei
1800 neue infektionen und das ist wir
hatten jetzt mal eine woche da ging es
ein bisschen hoch das hat noch was zu
tun mit den letzten urlaubern die aus
den großen themen zurückgekommen sind
also man darf sich auch nicht
verschrecken lassen wenn die zahlen bei
einem besuch gucken aber man darf auch
nicht obwohl das immer wieder gesagt
wird nicht nach spanien nach frankreich
ins ausland gucken wo die zahlen
erschrecken katastrophal hoch sind die
machen irgendetwas völlig anders als wir
ich vermag es auch nicht von hier zu
erkennen was da schief läuft aber bei
uns läuft es jedenfalls von den sachen
die man machen kann
absolut richtig wir haben abstand und
desinfektion und mehr kann man ja auch
nicht machen man kann es jetzt nur noch
kontrollieren und die bevölkerung bitten
aber gegebenenfalls natürlich dann auch
mit ordnungsstrafen aktiv werden wenn
sich leute mich mal halten denn es geht
ja schließlich um auch nicht nur um den
einzelnen sondern um das wohl der
gemeinschaft aber ich bin nicht so
besorgt wie viele andere offenbar weil
ich diese jahreszeitliche abhängigkeit
auch nicht erkennen kann
es war ja auch in der vergangenheit
nicht so also es wurden ja auch noch
ganz andere vorhersagen gemacht in
abhängigkeit von einer auszeit aber die
kann man eigentlich im großen ganzen
vergessen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren